[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend in Berlin saßen sie heute wieder
zusammen und sten in Abgründe so groß
und tief dass man von Löchern
Haushaltslöchern kaum noch sprechen kann
und so tief wie die finanziellen
Abgründe sind auch die politischen
Gräben die sich in der Ampelkoalition
auftun was die einen wollen kommt für
die andere nicht in Frage aber
irgendeine Lösung muss es bald geben das
Jahr 2024 rückt unerbittlich näher und
hat noch keinen Haushalt aus Berlin
frankbchwal selten sind Spitzentreffen
so geheim es geht um den Haushalt um
sparen die granten der Ampel am ersten
Advent im Kanzleramt keiner in Berlin
will verraten dass der Termin überhaupt
stattfindet koalitionspoker bei
Kerzenschein und keiner lässt sich in
die Karten schauen auch der SPD general
Sekretär nicht bei Berlin direkt genau
in diesen Stunden sitzen Menschen hinter
verschlossenen Türen und tun das was man
in Demokratien bei
Meinungsverschiedenheiten miteinander
macht man verhandelt miteinander nicht
im Fernsehstudio nicht in Talkshows
sondern dort wo im vertraulichen Rahmen
Lösung gefunden werden müssen woher aber
soll das Geld kommen weniger ausgeben
sagt die FDP etwa beim Bürgergeld jeder
dritte Euro den die Bundesregierung
ausgibt fließt in Sozialausgaben das
geht nicht mehr deshalb ist es jetzt
dringend notwendig das Bürgergeld neu zu
bewerten die geplante Erhöhung zum 1
Januar ist nicht mehr
angemessen streichen im Sozialbudget das
sehen die beiden anderen ampelpartner
völlig anders Zustimmung dagegen aus der
Opposition nicht mehr Bürgergeld sein
nötig sondern mehr
Beschäftigung wenn wir nämlich mehr
Menschen in Arbeit Brechten dann hätte
das einen dreifacheffekt erstens die
Betroffenen selber hätten dann mehr Geld
z Verfügung zweitens mal wir würden das
Bürgergeld im Staatshaushalt sparen und
wir hätten mehr Steuereinnahmen und
Einzahlung in die Sozialkassen mehr Geld
dringend gesucht auf der Website der
Förderbank KfW sind viele der
ehrgeizigen Subventionen aus dem
klimafond nicht mehr abrufbar wegen der
Haushaltssperre Prestigeprojekte der
Grünen die überall sparen wollen nur
nicht beim
ökombau wir brauchen eine gute Lösung
das bedeutet zum einen Abbau klimaschäd
Subventionen allein das
Dienstwagenprivileg 1,8 Milliarden die
wir einnehmen könnten und klar ist auch
dass die Schuldenbremse nicht zu einer
zukunftsbremse werden darf die
Schuldenbremse aber will Finanzminister
Lindner partu nicht lösen
koalitionspoker eben knallhart und von
vorweihnachtlicher Besinnlichkeit
Lichtjahre
entfernt tja die anderzimmermann in
Berlin das klingt jetzt alles nicht so
als sei man sich bei den Gesprächen
heute irgendwie näher kommen
ähm nein bzw wissen wir das nicht so
genau was wir wissen ist dass der
Kanzler der Wirtschaftsminister und der
Finanzminister sich gegen 15 Uhr im
Kanzleramt getroffen haben um 18 Uhr war
schon der brasilianische Präsident zum
Abendessen geladen bis dahin gab es
keinen Durchbruch allerdings hieß es
heute Abend dass Robert Harbeck seine
Reise zur Weltklimakonferenz die er
eigentlich morgen antreten wollte
verschoben hat die Anwesenheit des
Ministers sei notwendig um die Gespräche
um den Haushalt voranzubringen so hieß
es aus dem Ministerium das weckt die
Hoffnung oder die Erwartung dass die
Ampel sich vielleicht doch noch einigen
könnte vor Mittwoch wenn
Kabinettssitzung ist und nur wenn das
gelingt können die parlamentarischen
Termine so eingehalten werden dass eine
Verabschiedung des Haushalts
2024 noch in diesem Jahr möglich ist
wenn man sich jetzt anschaut wie die
Positionen in dieser Woche waren so ist
aber klar dass noch sehr weite Brücken
zu schlagen sind wie die Ampel der deren
Positionen in dieser Woche so weit
auseinander zu liegen scheinen wir
überhaupt noch nie sich da einigen das
wird diese Woche sehr spannendm danke
schön Diana nach Berlin und dann blicken
wir in den Nahen Osten im Roten Meer ist
offenbar ein US-amerikanisches
Kriegsschiff angegriffen worden mit
drohen oder Raketen mutmaßlich von
jemenitischen huthis auch Handelsschiffe
wurden erneut beschossen in den letzten
Wochen hatte es bereits mehrfach solche
Attacken gegeben die mit Iran
Verbündeten huthis begründen ihre
Attacken auf israelische Schiffe mit dem
Gazakrieg ein Bekenntnis dazu dass sie
jetzt auch ein amerikanisches Schiff
angegriffen haben gibt es noch nicht es
zeigt jedenfalls wie gefährlich schnell
sich die Konflikte im Nahen Osten
ausweiten können der Krieg geht derball
weiter die Hamas hat letzte Nacht wieder
Tel Aviv mit Raketen beschossen und die
israelische Armee verstärkt ihre
Angriffe im Süden des Gazastreifens
luten leinhus
berichtet die geheimen tunnelschächte
der Hamas Terroristen zerstören eines
der wichtigsten Ziele der israelischen
Bodenoffensive im Norden des
Gazastreifens immer wieder werden die
Soldaten fündig mehr als 500 dieser
Eingänge sind seit Kriegsbeginn
gesprengt worden sagt die
Regierung viele dieser Schächte wurden
in oder in der Nähe ziviler Gebäude
gefunden darunter Moscheen Schulen und
Spielplätze er Eingang ins Hamas
Tunnelsystem er befindet sich laut Armee
nur 15 m von einer Schule die vor 10
Jahren mit deutscher Entwicklungshilfe
errichtet wurde diese Einsätze so
Israels Militär am Abend werden von nun
an auch im Süden
stattfinden wir weiten unsere
Bodenoperationen gegen die Zentren der
Hamas auf den gesamten Gazastreifen aus
Israels Luftangriffe gingen heute im
Süden weiter vor allem die Stadt hanunis
wurde hart getroffen in vielen
Krankenhäusern herrscht der
Ausnahmezustand nur wenige Kilometer
entfernt Dieses Zeltlager in das sich
viele Menschen aus dem Norden geflüchtet
haben muntaha ist hier mit ihrer
achtköpfigen Familie
untergekommen so viele sind gestorben
Gaza Stadt ist zerstört nun trifft
esunis und wir sollen jetzt nach
gehen sie hat ebenfalls davon gehört
dass Israel die Menschen noch weiter in
den Süden zu gehen in die stad
Raffa wie sollen wir es jetzt nach Raffa
schaffen auch dort ist es gefährlich wir
bleiben
hier sie wollen weiterkämpfen für die
Rückkehr ihrer Liebsten auf dem Platz
der Geiseln in Tel Aviv sie wollen dass
alle nach Hause
kommen le per ist regelrecht verzweifelt
seit israels Regierung vor d Tagen die
Feuerpause beendet hat und auch die
Verhandlung der sein Vater ist noch in
der Gewalt der
Terroristen die Regierung hat sie
geopfert es sind genug geiselnfrei
denken sie und wollen nun den Krieg
weiterführen für uns ist das schwer zu
verstehen dass wir unsere Liebsten
vielleicht nie mehr
wiedersehen seine Kritik zielt direkt
auf Ministerpräsident netan das Ziel die
Geiseln Leben zurückzuholen habe der
einer schnellen Fortsetzung des Krieges
gegen die Hamas
untergeordnet und darüber wollen wir mit
einer der profiliertesten israelischen
PolitikerInnen sprechen mit CIP Livni
sie war im Laufe vieler Jahrzehnte in
vielen Regierungsämtern als
vizepremierministerin als
Außenministerin als Justizministerin
guten Abend Frau le good evening einen
schönen guten Abend in Tel Aviv hat es
heute auch wieder Demonstration gegeben
wir haben es eben gesehen von
Angehörigen von Geiseln die verzweifelt
sind es es scheint dass es nicht möglich
ist gleichzeitig Geiseln zu befreien und
die Hamas niederzukämpfen wie soll
dieses Dilemma aufgelöst
werden na wir denken dass die Dinge
schon Zusammenhängen denn das was die
Hamas getan hat ist so etwas Furchtbares
dass wir das zunächst einmal verstehen
müssen die
Familienangehörigen bangen natürlich um
Ihre Liebsten die von der Hamas gefangen
gehalten werden und da haben wir eben
nicht nur das Recht sondern sogar die
Verpflichtung für diese geliebten
Menschen zu kämpfen und das ist auch die
Aufgabe des der israelischen Regierung
deshalb wird Druck auf die Hamas
ausgeübt und es sieht so aus als wäre
dieses erste
Militärmanöver das wirklich dazu geführt
hat dass einige der gefangenen Frauen
und Kinder freigelassen wurden andere
sind nach vorgefangen und das heißt
israel muss einfach weitermachen mit der
Militäroperation darf nicht nachlassen
nicht aufgeben und muss für die
Freilassung dieser Menschen kämpfen im
Gasastreifen passieren jetzt aber auch
grauenvolle Dinge zumal wenn dieser
Krieg jetzt nach Süden ausgeweitet werd
und quasi 2 Millionen Menschen von der
einen erst in die andere Ecke geschoben
und jetzt wieder zurückgeschoben werden
und von der amerikanischen Führung sind
sehr sehr deutliche Wochen Worte jetzt
an diesem Wochenende gefunden worden die
Vizepräsidentin camala Harris sagt dass
des Leids dort sei verherend der
amerikanische Verteidigungsminister
warnt Israel davor am Ende eine
strategische Niederlage zu erreichen das
das kann ja eigentlich in Israel nicht
ungehört verhallen solche
Appelle nicht nur das haben sie gesagt
sondern auch im Einklang mit unseren
Werten mit unserem Rechtssystem handeln
wir wir sind eine Demokratie
dementsprechend Handel wir auch und wir
möchten natürlich kein Leid über die
Palästinenser bringen aber die Situation
ist sehr schwierig und das heißt Leben
Palästinenser dort in Gaza die Hamas
durchdringt das gesamte System und die
führenden
Köpfe bzw es wurde auch gefragt warum
werden z.B dieses diese Tunnelsysteme
nicht geöffnet für die Bevölkerung im
Gazastreifen und die Antwort war die war
ehrlich gesagt erschreckend denn da
wurde abgeunken sozusagen es wurde
überhaupt nicht als Möglichkeit in
Betracht gezogen das heißt die das Leid
der Familien der
Zivilisten Zivilbevölkerung auf beiden
Seiten ist natürlich viel Leid das
schwer zu ertragen ist das heißt es
handelt sich nicht darum den Schmerz
abzuwegen oder zu vergleichen der
Familien auf beiden Seiten und ich
möchte auch nicht dass die Welt
wegschaut und nicht wahrnimmt was in der
Region passiert und was wir dort tun
aber man soll auch wirklich das
jeweilige Wertesystem das Zug Grunde
liegt in Betracht ziehen denn das was
die Hamas tut ist wirklich Massaker
Vergewaltigung grueltaten und wir
versuchen zivile Opfer zu vermeiden und
es ist natürlich auch schwierig das
hinzubekommen aber die einzige
Möglichkeit dass Gaza frei sein kann
dass die Menschen dort in Freiheit
Wohlstand und Hoffnung leben können ist
es wenn die Hammers nicht mehr existiert
und wenn dann auch diese Menschen das
Existenzrechts Israels anerkennen und
Terrorismus ablehnen und das ist nicht
nur mein Appell Hier und Jetzt sondern
das ist doch der Appell der
internationalen Gemeinschaft seit
als wir uns zurückgezogen haben aus dem
Gazastreifen und für die Zukunft der
Palästinenser im Gazastreifen möchte ich
wirklich hoffen dass es genauso kommen
wird und je früher wir das erreichen und
desto besser ist es für die Bevölkerung
dort und für Israel natürlich auch haben
sie denn den Eindruck dass die aktuelle
Regierung irgendeinen Plan hat was dann
mit Gaza geschehen
soll da gibt es auch interne
Diskussionen in Israel der wird
wahrscheinlich auch außen wahrgenommen
und die
Regierung na natürlich gibt es
Befürworter des der Lösung der zwei
staatenlösung aber es gibt auch in der
Opposition Unterstützung und ich denke
man muss sich jetzt auch an die Zeit
danach wenden und überlegen was die
verschiedenen Parteien in der Region
natürlich auch Grenze hin zu Ägypten zu
den
Golfstaaten und auch im Dialog mit den
USA denn ich denke das Ende dieses
Krieges wird sich so gestalten dass es
Parameter geben wird über die man eklang
finden werden muss und
dass man sehen muss dass
es keine
Terrororganisation geben darf die Terror
unterstützt es muss aber auch Kräfte
geben Terror zu bekämpfen und das heißt
es sind sollte doch übereinstimmend
möglich sein es so zu sehen in der
internationalen Gemeinschaft und dass
wir natürlich in Israel die Möglichkeit
den Willen haben müssen in diese
Richtung zu
arbeiten und ich denke die
Grundvoraussetzung ist wirklich dass
Hamas eben nicht die Kraft an der Macht
sein darf im
gazaastreifen und dass wir eben eine
legitime Regierung in Gazastreifen im
Westjordanland brauchen und dann eben
auch friedensverhandlung voranbringen
können wir haben das bisher nicht
geschafft aber ich hege die Hoffnung und
ich denke dass das die Verantwortung auf
beiden Seiten sein muss Frau Liv danke
ihn für das
Interview thank
you das Gespräch haben wir vor einer
Stunde geführt der Gazakrieg wird nun
auch von Terroristen in Europa als Motiv
benutzt so wie gestern in Paris damit
beginnen bei dir die Nachrichten Hanna
bei einer Messerattacke nah des Pariser
Eifelturms ist gestern Abend ein
deutscher Tourist getötet worden der
mutmaßliche Täter hat sich in einem
Video zum islamischen Staat bekannt das
teilte am Abend die Pariser Staats
Anwaltschaft mit auf seiner Flucht
verletzte der Mann zwei weitere Personen
und konnte dann festgenommen werden laut
dem französischen Innenminister dman war
der Angreifer den Behörden als Islamist
bekannt und hat erhebliche psychische
Probleme bei seiner Festnahme habe er
sich wütend über den Gazakrieg geäußert
und Frankreich daran eine Mitschuld
gegeben der 26-Jährige hat bereits wegen
der Planung eines Anschlags für vier
Jahre im Gefängnis
gesessen kievs Bürgermeister klitschko
hat in einem Interview deutliche Kritik
am ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski
geäußert unter anderem forderte er einen
ehrlicheren Blick auf die Lage an der
Front man könne das Volk und die Partner
nicht ewig euphorisch anlügen sagte
Klitschko gegenüber dem Schweizer
Nachrichtenportal 20 Minuten zuvor hatte
der Oberkommandierende der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte von einer patsituation im
Krieg gesprochen und war dafür von
selenski kritisiert worden
nach den starken Schneefällen im Süden
Deutschlands normalisiert sich die Lage
nur langsam am Flughafen München wurde
heute der Flugbetrieb wieder aufgenommen
aber mehr als zwei Drittel der geplanten
Flüge wurden annulliert auch viele Züge
fallen weiterhin aus die Bahn hat
Reisenden geraten auch für morgen
geplante Fahrten wenn möglich zu
verschieben und auch in NRW
Behinderungen die A1 bei Wuppertal war
zeitweise geschwert weil dort Eis
Platten von einer Brücke gefallen waren
sei niemand zu Schaden gekommen sagte
ein
Polizeisprecher in nordrin-westfalen ist
der Kühlturm des 2017 stillgelegten
Steinkohlekraftwerks Förde gesprengt
worden der
165 m hohe Turm fiel heute Vormittag um
kurz nach 11 uh planmäßig und ohne
Probleme in sich zusammen das Gelände
wurde weiträumig abgesperrt der
Energiekonzern RWE prüft ob er auf dem
Areal künft grünen Wasserstoff
produzieren kann wie jedes Jahr am
ersten Advent sind die bundesweiten
Spendenaktionen der Kirchen gestartet
das evangelische Hilfswerk Brot für die
Welt eröffnete seine Spendensammlung mit
einem Festgottesdienst im Mittelpunkt
steht dabei der Kampf gegen den Hunger
Altbundespräsident gaug mahnte dass in
einer Welt des Überflusses immer noch
mehr als 800 Millionen Menschen hungern
müssten das katholische Hilfswerk
advenia nimmt bei seiner Spendenaktion
das Thema Flucht in den
Fokus vor 85 Jahren kam in der
englischen Stadt herid der erste Zug aus
Deutschland an ein
Kindertransport dieses deutsche Wort
wird in Großbritannien bis heute dafür
verwendet dahinter stehen tausende
Schicksale jüdischer Kinder die ab
1938 nach den Novemberpogrom von ihren
Eltern nach Großbritannien geschickt
wurden für Erwachsene waren die
Möglichkeit zu fliehen beschränkt viele
Länder hatten ihre Einreisebestimmungen
für jüdische Flüchtlinge bereits
verschärft wenigstens die Kinder sollten
in Sicherheit gebracht werden und so
reisten sie ganz alleine in ein fremdes
Land viele haben ihre Eltern nie
wiedergesehen daran erinnert Hilke
Petersen R schwiening und ihr Mann jür
in Rut auffüender Vergangenheit haben
sie viel
recherchiert ist drei als sie nach
England kommt ohne ihre jüdischen Eltern
die Züge voller Kinder nach London
arrangiert vor allem von jüdischen
Organisationen und engagierten Menschen
1938 und 39 um Kinder wie Rut vor den
Nazis zu
retten es ist ein bedeutender Teil
meines Lebens mein Hinterland damit muss
ich klarkommen und umgehen das ist mein
Leben viele Abschiede am Bahnhof sind
für immer jüdische Kinder besteigen Züge
in Berlin Prag oder Wien kurz bevor der
Krieg beginnt ein Koffer ein Foto sind
erlaubt der harte Moment aus der
Erinnerung der kleinen Rut
verschwunden das ist wohl auch gut so
ich habe Freunde die sich an ihre Eltern
erinnern und dann kam die Nachricht dass
sie ermordet wurden ich erinnere
nicht bei der Ankunft in London werden
die Kinder britischen Pflegeeltern
zugeteilt oder müssen in
Kinderheime am Londoner Bahnhof
Liverpool Street treffen sie sich heute
wo die Kindertransporte aus Europa
ankamen vor 85 Jahren die Kinder von
damals heute hoch betagt und der
britischen Wahlheimat meistens
dankbar auch er kam mit dem
Kindertransport Lord Alfs mit 91 noch
immer politisch aktiv im Oberhaus als
sechjähriger verlässt alleinag ineutter
kann bald folgen vor allem Asylpolitik
hat er als Abgeordneter gemacht und
denkt nach über britische
Aufnahmebereitschaft heute und vor 85
Jahren die Briten damals hießen uns
weitgehen willkommen danach kamen
unterschiedliche Wellen von
Asylsuchenden doch der brexit
schließlich verursachte großen Schaden
denn der Slogan Kontrolle zurückgewinnen
wurde von vielen so verstanden dass es
am Ende hieß lasst niemanden mehr
rein
zum Gedenktag hat die Vereinigung
jüdischer Flüchtlinge gerade eine Reise
nach Berlin
organisiert mit dabei Rut schwiening und
Kurt Marx auch ein Kind vom Londoner
Kindertransport auf dem Programm
bundestagsbesuch und eben
erinnern zu Hause in England ist
rutkünstlerin ihre Familiengeschichte
Thema die Eltern holen Tochter Rut nach
knapp eineinhalb Jahren bei ihrer
Pflegefamilie wieder ab doch sie bleiben
sich
fremd meine Kunst fröhlich und verspielt
aber am Ende kommt doch immer dies zum
Vorschein nicht nur Kindertransport auch
Krieg mehr als eine Million Kinder
sterben in den Vernichtungslagern der
Nazis die Kindertransporte retteten etwa
1000 und jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal
weiter han mit Meldungen vom Sport und
da beginnen wir mit der fßb Bundesliga
drei Begegnungen an diesem Sonntag
main05 verlor gegen den SC Freiburg 0:1
der Tabellenerste Bayer Leverkusen und
Borussia Dortmund trennten sich
unentschieden 1 zu ein und außerdem
spielte der FC Augsburg gegen Eintracht
Frankfurt entstand
2:1 es war ein erfolgreicher Tag für die
deutschen biatletinnen und biatleten zum
Abschluss des Weltcups im schwedischen
Östersund ist Philip nafrad in der
Verfolgung auf Platz Z gelaufen und hat
damit die Führung im Gesamtweltcup
verteidigt nach 12,5 km musste er sich
nur dem Schweden Sebastian Samuelson
geschlagen geben bei den Frauen kam die
gesamtweltcupführende Franziska Preu in
der Verfolgung ebenfalls auf den zweiten
Platz ihre Teamkollegin Vanessa Vogt auf
den dritten erste wurde die Französin
Lou Jean
monau beim Skisprung Weltcup im
norwegischen Lillehammer hat
Olympiasieger Andreas Wellinger erneut
einen bestestplatz geholt der 28-Jährige
Bayer sprang auf der Großschanze
135 und 143 m weit und belegte damit
Rang 2 Sieger war einmal mehr der
Österreicher Stefan Kraft Karl Geiger
verpasste das Podest als Vierter nur
knapp und jetzt haben wir noch etwas
Erbauliches für die Sinne und blicken
dazu auf einen Ort mit dem
verheißungsvollen Namen Paradise der
liegt in der Wüste von Nevada bei Las
Vegas dort steht the fear von einer
merzweckhalle zu sprechen wäre etwas zu
schnöde handelt es sich doch um die
größte Kugel der Welt mit dem größten
hochauflösenden
ledbildschirm aller Zeiten das an sich
ist schon ein Fest für Fans von
Superlativen the fear macht seit seiner
Eröffnung Ende September vore was
weniger bekannt ist noch revolutionärer
als Architektur und Bildschirm ist die
Akustik möglich dank einer weltweit
einmaligen Spezialanfertigung und dieser
Sound ist Made in Germany Christian von
Rechenberg hat seine Erfinder
getroffen eigentlich kommen aus dem
Lautsprecher im Hintergrund gerade zwei
Geräusche gleichzeitig den Hubschrauber
hört man aber nur im linken Feld den
Straßenlärm nur im rechten Feld der
Schall ist gerichtet wie bitte geht
sowas bei nur einem
Lautsprecher es ist eigentlich eine
Kombination von vielen kleinen
einzelwellen die sich zusammenfügen zuur
einer neuen großen Welle die man dann
steuern kann Schallwellen steuern das
ist Spitzentechnologie sie ist zwar
nicht ganz neu aber das kleine Berliner
Startup Holo Plot beherrscht diese
Technik perfekt dermaßen perfekt dass
eines Tages die Madison Square Garden
company aus Amerika anruft mit einem
Auftrag baut uns das Soundsystem für the
sphere für einen gigantischen LED
videoball in Paradise
Nevada die akustische Erfahrung ist
komplett anders als bei ein normalen
Audio System das fühlt sich viel intimer
an man hat den Eindruck es ist nah dass
ein mehr unter die Haut geht wie nah
zeigt ein Ausschnitt aus einem you
Konzert man beginnt zu verstehen warum
sie hier soundm in Germany haben
wollten ichb dieösung die wir haben
einzigartig ist weil es mit
konventioneller Technologie einfach
nicht in dem Maße funktioniert hätte das
hat etwas mit der Konstruktion der
Halbkugel zu tun an ihren gekurvten
Wänden würden Schallwellen normaler
Lautsprecher abrallen das Ergebnis wäre
ein Soundbrei eine
klangkatastrophe das Audiosystem von
holoplot umgeht das Problem versteckt
installierte Soundmodule schicken den
Schall gezielt zum Publikum keine
Reflektion as Klang bis in die letzte
Reihe dadurch könnte man das
Showprogramm sogar gleichzeitig in
verschiedenen Sprachen anbieten oder mit
verschiedenen Instrumenten was die
wenigsten wissen das ganze Video
Wunderland ist ein riesiges Soundsystem
in dem mehr als 160 000 solcher
Lautsprecher ihren Dienst tun jeder
einzeln angesteuert und all samt
hochintelligent verschaltet der Rest ist
Betriebsgeheimnis also es war
äh war schon nicht immer ganz leichter
Weg äh als wir angefangen haben auch
weil es eine komplett neue Technologie
ist es ist relativ komplex und es gab
einfach viele fragen wo man nicht wusste
ob das nachher funktioniert es
funktioniert und you2 die noch bis
Februar in the sphere Spielen haben die
Soundanlage auch schon geadelt mit einem
Wort Rock and
Roll wer das sehen und vor allem hören
will der billigste Platz für das Youtube
Konzert in the fear kostet umgerechnet
rund 300 € und der teuerste mehr als 16
000 € dafür muss man dann wohl erstmal
nach Las Vegas und Glück im Spiel haben
gleich gibt's noch das Wetter und zuvor
unser sonntäglicher Ausblick auf die
nächste Woche den liefert Christiane
[Musik]
Hoffmann am Dienstag wird die CD die
Ergebnisse ihrer neuen Pisa Studie
vorstellen schwerpunktmäßig geht es
diesmal um die Kompetenzen der
15-Jährigen in Mathematik eigentlich
erscheint die Studie alle dre Jahre
wegen der coronapandemie wurde sie
diesmal um ein Jahr verschoben und die
Leistungen im Jahr 2022
abgefragt die Linke Bundestagsfraktion
wird sich am Mittwoch auflösen nach dem
Austritt von SAR Wagenknecht und neun
anderen Abgeordneten aus der Partei hat
die Linke ihren Status verloren die
jetzt 28 Abgeordneten wollen als Gruppe
weitermachen damit verbunden sind unter
anderem weniger Geld und Redezeit im
Bundestag von Freitag bis Sonntag hält
die SPD ihren Bundesparteitag auf der
Berliner Messe und nicht wie vor zwei
Jahren überwiegend online ab dabei wird
es auch um die Haushaltskrise der
Regierung gehen um Forderungen die
Schuldenbremse abzuschaffen und die
Steuern für Reiche zu erhöhen die
Parteivorsitzenden Klingbeil und esken
wollen sich erneut wählen
lassen die iranische Frauenrechtlerin
Nargis Mohammadi wird am Sonntag in Oslo
den Friedensnobelpreis erhalten in
Abwesenheit denn Mohammadi sitzt im
Gefängnis sie werde vor allem für ihren
Kampf gegen die Unterdrückung der Frauen
im Iran ausgezeichnet so das
Nobelkomitee die anderen diesjährigen
Nobelpreise werden auch am Sonntag in
Stockholm
übergeben und jetzt der Ausblick auf das
winterliche Wetter morgen kommt im
Südwesten gefrierender Regen auf der
sich weiter bis zur Mitte ausdehnt dabei
wird es teilweise gefährlich glatt auf
Straßen und Gehwegen sonst ist es
überwiegend trocken die Temperaturen
liegen zwischen -4 und + 6° in den
nächsten Tagen sind weitere Schnee und
Regenschauer dabei anfangs noch mit
Glätte der Frost schwächt sich dann
etwas ab -1 bis +
6° das war's von uns gleich geht's dann
mit dem son tagsrimy weiter und die
nächsten Nachrichten gibt's hier gegen
0:30 Uhr morgen gibt's natürlich wieder
ein heute journal auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
tschüss